oui mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
que cette question du consensus qui est
une question importante façon il est
mort donc il ya aussi le respect par
rapport à la mort
mais il ya aussi une autre chose c'est
que il ya une forme effectivement ne
peut-être de faussetés parfois du
consensus je regardais ce qui s'est
passé autour du tweet d'alexis corbières
ce matin qui a osé dire ça somistes
voilà de la france dans tout l'est de la
france est soumise qui a osé dire johnny
est mort mais la politique continue il
ya eu une espèce de de d'indignations
c'était juste pour réagir par rapport à
ce qu'a dit stéphane marchand c'est à
dire que je crois que tout homme
politique ne souhaitent pas forcément le
consensus a priori autour de sa personne
et donc la question du débat d'idées
elle continue je pense en revanche
johnny hallyday avait cette espèce de
force humaine d'énergie incroyable qui
au fond lui attiré les sympathies de la
gauche et de la droite et c'était
authentique après le débat d'idées
politiques il doit continuer on doit pas
rester dans l'émotion indéfiniment